Howard A. Rodman: Hi, I’m Howard Rodman.
I’m president of the Writers Guild West
and also Chair of the 2017 USC Scripter Selection
Committee.
Film Courage: We’re curious what you would
recommend to beginning writers on trying to
present their first screenplay or protect
their work.
What are some of the few things you recommend?
Howard A. Rodman: First thing I recommend
to beginning writers is that the only way
that I absolutely guarantee that you will
not have a career as a writer is to quit.
So what I recommend to beginning writers is,
real simple, real basic, is that you write
every day in terms of getting our work out
there in the world.
If you’re shy or a shoegazer, you have to
be aggressive on behalf of your work and get
it into the hands of anyone who might conceivably
read it, as painful and humiliating as that
process is.
In terms of protecting your work you should
absolutely copyright it.
Put the C in the circle.
Get the form from the U.S. Copyright Office.
The forms are online.
It’s really simple.
And also register with the Writer’s Guild.
The two give very complimentary protections
for work for new people.
Film Courage: You are a writer, as well?
You’ve written screenplays?
Can you share with us the first film that
inspired you to want to write?
Howard A. Rodman: I’m a writer.
See the calluses [holds up his hands to the
camera].
And there are so many films that inspired
me to want to write that to pick one I think
would be crazy.
But I think I remember there is a scene at
the opening of an old Film Noir boxing movie
called BODY AND SOUL, I believe written by
Abraham Lincoln Polonsky, Directed by Robert
Rossen.
And there is a boxer, a very proud, sort of
first generation, scrappy immigrant boxer
played by John Garfield and the mob boss is
offering him a lot of money not to win the
fight.
All the money has been bet the other way.
And John Garfield starts talking about his
pride and his morals and the ethics of throwing
a fight and the mob boss turns to him and
says “There is addition.
There is subtraction.
The rest is conversation.”
And I just thought “Wow!
If I could just like write one of those!”
And I think for many of us we start reading
books and watching movies because somebody
has built a world and we can just hide in
that world for awhile and then you realize.
“Oh, wait!
I could build me own sort of purpose-built
world that would really fit me.”
And so the transition from movie going to
reading to writing I think for many of us
is just a slow descent into the pit.
Film Courage: So the first screenplay that
you wrote did you have the similar sort of
dream that this was going to be the first
ONE and it would put you on the map Like so
many new writers think that the first screenplay
will open doors.
Actually even the first draft [of a first
screenplay].
Howard A. Rodman: I never had any thoughts
like that.
I spent well over a decade writing unpublishable
novels before I transitioned to writing unproduceable
screenplays.
So I was under no illusion.
I just started having ideas that were movies
that weren’t quite books.
And the first of those screenplays that I
wrote still has not been produced but I’ve
gotten tons and tons of work off of it.
It’s like of course “We can’t do this
because it’s too weird, BUT maybe you can
do that?”
And so I don’t think I ever really expected
frankly that anything I wrote would ever be
filmed.
And when things I write do get filmed, it
just strikes me as sort of the bonus rounds
in a pinball game.
It’s sort of unexpected and really lovely.
Film Courage: Wrapping up here.
I know you have to go.
Wondering what you see as the most common
mistakes or somethings new writers should
be weary of regarding formatting, structure,
things like that?
Howard A. Rodman: I would tell beginning writers
not to worry too much about about formatting
and structure.
In terms of formatting there are many really
good software programs and some of them you
can get for free and so let them worry about
the formatting.
In terms of the structure, I think you can’t
say “My God!
My first act didn’t end on page 29.
I’m a bad writer” if you find real living
characters through telling a story that only
you can tell or write about a place in the
world that you know better than anybody else,
just let the story tell itself, or let the
characters tell the story and the rest will
fall into place.
Film Courage: So in other words, for lack
of a better term, get the vomit draft, please
excuse my crass analogy, but get that out
and worry about all the other things later?
Howard A. Rodman: No, I wouldn’t even say
that.
I would say…I was the editor-in-chief of
my college newspaper.
And there is a big sign in the newspaper office
underneath this huge clock, that had a blood
red second hand and the sign said “This
is a daily, not a weekly.”
And whenever we were there past midnight the
managing editor would put up another sign
that would say “Don’t get it right, get
it written.”
And I would say the same thing to anyone starting
out writing and to people who have been writing
all of their lives.
Film Courage: I love it!
Thank you!